the Joe Rogan experience Kalen spars all
the time and doesn't bro anyone yeah
Brian oh no Brian cannot DJ Khaled one
person is not doing any cardio it's DJ
calories after Ruiz one Khaled getting
out of a car with all the big guys the
day after Khaled Khaled Khaled been
working out on snapchat for a whole
Union didn't lose a [ __ ] pounds
this guy and got a Weight Watchers deal
god bless america
yeah Weight Watchers I mean we are
there's a washing lightweight there's
plus-size models right there doing that
now like Nike and their Nike store has
like a big mannequin like a fat
mannequin but they don't they don't have
plus-size models for men Joe
there is nothing that enrages me more
than fat models there is nothing that
enrages me more than fat [ __ ] okay okay
let me just say something as a comic we
want attention we don't feel like we
deserve it so we make you laugh so
there's an even exchange I get my
attention you get some joy okay an actor
they want attention they're not willing
to write the script but they'll memorize
some line so do a little bit of effort
to get the attention a regular model at
least she's willing to lose weight so
that she can be looked at but these fat
[ __ ] are just like look at me you to
be looked at app using the word [ __ ]
in 2019 what the [ __ ] that's that's
that's the plus-size model mannequin
rate you guys the only thing I don't
like and rage you that they're like just
stare at me I'm gonna eat bread all day
no but you should stare at me the only
thing that bothers me about that is
that's out of context cuz that's the
oversized mannequin in workout clothes
right he's going to lose the weight yeah
she's trying to lose herself okay so I
needed some context if this is workout
gear like overweight women who want to
go lose weight cool right other than
that why are you wearing workout gear
cuz she's trying to lose weight that's
the only reason you'd be wearing that
she would she'd be even bigger if she
didn't work out she like Hallett imagine
calleb dignity DJ khaled needs to eat a
salad
[Laughter]
you gotta have a DJ Khaled level of
annoyance to succeed in life go to you
yes you do so much but yeah it's so much
she's gettin your [ __ ] shirt there's
no way you didn't know you could button
your shirt he's the epitome of not being
afraid to ask for things but he looks
like french toast Jesus every time I
look at him it's french toast and he has
no easily where's the butter and the
maple syrup says he lost 15 kilograms
what is that 34 pounds yeah no there you
go lost 34 pounds
okay listen congratulate he can see his
big now congratulations there's a little
slimmer on the right he does look a
little slimmer okay maybe it's a little
whoa Christ I don't even know what that
is are we watching I respect that Callie
came from Radio
[Applause]